how is this going to work yeah the news
is finally out it looks like it's a lot
of the reporting before is sort of ben
baird out here it's going to be a
national service a lot of ways a lot of
the 4g areas will be covered it's going
to work with Wi-Fi and interesting lee
enough you're gonna have sort of a
twenty-dollar basic monthly fee and then
you sort of pay extra for you know data
data from that now we'll see how many
people want to use that how many people
are going to adopt it but they are
partnering as we reported on with
t-mobile and Sprint how does this fit
into Google's broader ambitions with
Google Fiber the Google moon project all
efforts to bring the Internet to people
are we gonna have google services you
know beyond the search engine like
youtube forced on us it is a great
question i think that there is this is
yes another get another step in this
lets get access to everywhere and i
think that this one is more about really
interesting what the consumers are doing
day to day with those mobile phones so
this will give a lot of great insights
it'll be about pushing the industry
forward but yeah it is yet another thing
that they're doing what the super really
works